cleansing is really important
when you start off with skin care everyone
is really excited about actives
exfoliants retinoids vitamin C
people kind of assume cleansing isn't that
important because cleanser is only on your
skin for a little bit you wash it off
it doesn't really matter what you use
that is completely wrong
cleansing is the step of your routine
where your skin is at its most vulnerable
the barrier gets disturbed and
can stay disturbed for hours
a cleansing routine that isn't right for your skin
can lead to breakouts rough and
flaky dehydrated skin irritation
I noticed a huge difference in my skin since
I found the right cleansing routine
and I hope this video helps you too
hi I'm michelle of lab muffin beauty
science and I am a big cleanser advocate
today I'm going to do a deep
dive into the different types
of cleansing products and
how they fit into a routine
this video is sponsored by stylekorean who
stock the products I'll be mentioning today
the most basic central kind of
cleanser is the wash off cleanser
it might be the first
skincare product you ever used
what to look for in a cleanser
there are a lot of myths around
a lot of them are based on outdated
information or brand marketing
I talk more about picking and
using cleansers in my book the
lab muffin guide to basic skincare
but here are some of the main points
any form of a cleanser can be gentle
including bars and foaming cleansers
there are lots of ways to make cleansers
foam more without getting harsher
there are harsh and gentle cleansers with and
without foam it depends on the specific cleanser
moisturising and soothing
ingredients are a good sign
in general cleansers with more
different surfactants those are
cleansing ingredients and a pH
closer to skin 4-6 are gentler
there are exceptions to these general principles
formulation techniques and
ingredients are always improving
check reviews from people with similar skin to you
before you buy and if you can
try a sample on your own skin
how do you use a cleanser
there are lots of different
types of rinse off cleansers
the simplest sort of cleanser
is probably a foaming cleanser
to use these you squeeze out a small
amount lather it in your hands with
some water rub it over your face and
then rinse with slightly warm water
then you pat the water off
your face gently with a towel
with non-foaming cleansers you do the
same but without the lathering step
there are a few cleansers that have special
instructions so always check the label
how much cleanser should you use
there aren't really any strict rules on
this in general you just need enough to
spread around your face usually
around an almond sized amount
does your face need to be wet
before you apply the cleanser
again there isn't really
a right and a wrong answer
it's usually easier to use cleansers
on wet skin because the water already
on your face adds to it and there's
just more liquid to spread around
some cleansers can also stick to
dry skin and be hard to rinse off
but if you're removing makeup
or sunscreen then you probably
have to massage cleanser into your face for longer
so it might be less messy to apply to dry
skin and maybe skip the lathering step
there are also other products you can use for
removing makeup we'll talk more about that later
how long should you massage for
again there aren't strict rules you just
need to rub the cleanser on your skin for
long enough that the dirt and the oils
get lifted by the cleansing surfactants
there's no benefit to letting it soak on your
skin for longer and you might risk more irritation
you're giving any irritating ingredients a longer
time to burrow into your skin while it's
vulnerable and cause prolonged irritation
if a cleanser has actives the instructions
might say to leave it on for longer
the cleanser has been designed
and tested to be used that way
and yes active ingredients
can work in wash off cleansers
it's the same for moisturizing ingredients
cleansers can be formulated
so that some ingredients can
stay stuck to skin even through rinsing
the abib acne foam cleanser is a gentle
cleanser I've been really enjoying
it forms a nice foam and it
doesn't strip my skin which
is great because so many acne cleansers are harsh
it has salicylic acid in it to help with acne
it's been found to work well in
cleansers and you can see some
of those gentle cleanser formulation features here
there's a mix of surfactants
and a bunch of soothing and
moisturizing ingredients including
heartleaf and centella extracts
it's fragrance free apart
from those plant extracts
some cleansers come in self foaming pumps that mix
air into the cleanser so that
it makes the lather for you
they are super convenient
these cleansers are formulated
to be very runny so that they
work with the pump correctly but that
doesn't mean it's less concentrated
something I didn't realise until I started
learning about formulations is that for almost
every product the texture gets adjusted
with special thickening ingredients so
how thick a product is doesn't tell you
anything about how watered down it is
in fact for most cleansing surfactants
the texture is pretty thin when it's at
100% then it gets thicker when you add
more water and then it thins down again
so it's a myth that self foaming cleanses
are bad value because they're watered down
and you use them up faster it really
depends on the product and the pump
with this etude soon jung whip cleanser one
pump is 0.8 grams and that is
enough to clean my whole face
this is pretty similar to the
amounts of other cleansers I use
this is really gentle again you can see how
it has a lot of moisturizing and soothing
ingredients like panthenol and madecassoside
those are in the whole soon jung range
there's two surfactants which you might
think would be less gentle than more
surfactants but both of these are very gentle
on their own and often used in baby products
they even have a bit of a moisturizing
effect it's also fragrance free
so one cleanser is all you need for
a very basic cleansing routine but
you can also add steps before and
after if you wear makeup or a very
resilient sunscreen you might want to
use other products to get them off first
regular cleansers can remove these depending on
the cleanser and what you're removing but a lot
of people prefer to double cleanse which is very
popular in a lot of asian style skincare routines
basically this is where you wash your face
twice usually with two different cleansers
most commonly you start with an oil-based cleanser
like a cleansing balm or cleansing oil then
follow that with a regular foaming cleanser
oil based cleansers are really good
at shifting water resistant makeup
and sunscreens with minimal effort
and they are really relaxing to use
they also contain surfactants so when you
rinse with water the oil lifts
off your skin and washes away
some of these rinse off really cleanly
others leave an oily film that is
sometimes a feature of the product
the oils are meant to be beneficial
but some people find that they break out if
they don't use another cleanser afterwards
in terms of what to look for it is really about
preference what texture packaging fragrance you
want whether you want it to rinse off cleanly
or leave a film what active ingredients you like
to use a cleansing oil you massage about
an almond sized amount onto dry skin
i'm using the skin 1004 madagascar centella light
cleansing oil one of my favorite cleansing oils
it's very lightweight it has a lot of soothing
ingredients and it comes in a handy pump
it doesn't leave much residue afterwards
like with other cleansers cleansing oils don't
really cleanse better if you leave them sitting
on your skin for ages your skin is usually
clean after less than 30 seconds of rubbing
but if you massage them gently for a little bit
longer up to five minutes you
can get blackheads to pop out
the massaging and the oil loosens them it's
really satisfying when you feel these grits
there are lots of ways of encouraging
more grits to come out like letting the
oil soak into your pores before
you massage using a clay mask
i'll link a tutorial in the description
once you're done with that you rinse with water
the water will look milky that is the tiny
drops of oil coming off into the water
then you can either follow up with a second
cleanser or pat dry and go on with
the rest of your skincare routine
cleansing balms are used in pretty
much the same way except they're
more solid you scoop out a little
and massage it gently into dry skin
in colder places you might want to
melt it a bit in your hands first
I personally prefer cleansing balms because
they're a bit less messy to
get onto my face than an oil
this is the heimish all clean balm
one of my favorite cleansing balms
it shifts make up really easily it rinses
off cleanly it comes in a convenient flip
top tub and it's affordable i'd recommend this to
anyone unless you're allergic to something in it
this is their new mandarin version which is pretty
much the same as the original except for the scent
it's a slightly floral citrus essential oil smell
once you're done massaging you rinse it off
if you wear heavy eyeliner or lipstick you might
want to remove them with a separate product
if you want just the one product you can use a
cleansing oil or balm a lot of them are designed
to remove eye and lip makeup as well but I prefer
using a cotton pad with a two phase makeup remover
this is the illiyoon fresh moisture lip and eye
remover you can see there are
two layers of liquid inside
the top layer is oil based the
bottom is water-based so that
means it can dissolve both oily and watery makeup
you shake it up put a bit on your cotton
pad and wipe it over your eyes and lips
for really stubborn makeup you can hold the wet
pad over your makeup to let it soak in and soften
I find this faster to use than an
oil based cleanser because the pad
grabs onto makeup and gets into the skin
folds more easily than just my fingers
plus it's really easy to see whether
you have makeup left on your skin
some cleansing oils and balms can
also leave your eyes blurry for
a bit which generally isn't
harmful just a bit annoying
most of these removers use a
mix of lightweight oil so it
doesn't leave a noticeable residue
though you should check the reviews
this illiyoon one is really lightweight I use it
at the very start of my cleansing
routine before other cleanses
there are lots of rinse off treatments
that you can use after cleansing
I think of these as part of my cleansing routine
to prepare my skin before all the leave-on steps
one of my favorite underrated product
categories is peeling gels also called gommages
these are super gentle but very
thorough physical exfoliants
as you rub them into your skin they bunch up
into soft fibres it's like a super gentle scrub
you massage about an almond's worth gently into
your skin you'll feel those fibres bunching up
no those rolls are not dead skin removing
that much dead skin would hurt a lot
this is the beauty of joseon
apricot blossom peeling gel
the main scrubbing ingredient is cellulose
it also has exfoliating enzymes
in it to add to that effect
this can be used on wet or
dry skin but some peeling
gels will form a weird film on
wet skin that's hard to remove
make sure you check the instructions
after a minute or two of
massaging you rinse it off
I use it about twice a week but
it depends on your skin tolerance
I talk more about how to build up
an exfoliation routine in this guide
there are lots of different rinse off
masks that you can use at this stage
some of these can be annoying because they have to
be cleansed off so you end up cleansing
then masking and then cleansing again
a lot of clay masks are like this but there are
also clay cleansers like this one from
tocobo that do it all in the one step
it has clay particles that soak up oil
and exfoliate gently as you cleanse
if you have oily skin the clay can help to
soak up oil and keep your skin
from getting shiny for longer
so let's talk about what a cleansing
routine might look like the simplest
cleansing routine might simply look
like this use a cleanser like one of
these then apply your leave-on products
like essences serums and moisturizer
if you wear makeup or sunscreen
you might want to double cleanse
and then maybe have a separate
eye or lip makeup remover
you can also use other rinse off treatments
after cleansing like a peeling gel
that's a really quick rundown of how to cleanse
there's a lot about cleansing I didn't
get to in this video so check out my other
videos on cleansing and the lab muffin
basic skincare guide for more on this
links to all the products in the description
and happy getting stuff off your face